[Musique]
non moi c'est bien marrant ce crois que
dans ma première fois déjà la première
fois tmp est ce que c'était c'était un
peu stressant même temps hyper sympa
sert il était adorable et je crois quand
même que le dépassement de moi en
sautant en parachute pour tt c'était pas
mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ceci à base d'insectes qui voit
d'araignée de serpent de scorpions
franchement c'est pas les meilleurs
moments mais je suis pas son petit
copain
non mais t'es pas mon petit copain mais
tu vas prendre ma main dans ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] à les y attend balesi bateau oui
mais tu l'as pas vite mais bouge tes
fesses bédard je pense qu'à ce moment là
que tu es séries bien vite rejoint par
lens et l'inter portage en a rien à
[ __ ] son ordi qui veulent acheter
mais je crois le plus fou c'était sacha
baron cohen
tu sais borat parce que je pense que
c'est le seul qui a réussi à
déstabiliser un peu celle il ya le
mettre dans une situation parce qu'il
s'est enchaîné avec des menottes à
seville
si vous voyez un gars en train de
bricoler c'est normal si vous arrivez
voilà c'est juste que voilà on l'a dit
on l'a des menottes mais j'y crois pas
du tout et que trop bien on n'a pas les
clefs clé c'est pas on les a pas le tri
vous savez plus trop si jouets si je
vais pas vous toujours votre personnage
de film donc c'était un moment assez
entre 2 c'était incroyable
[Musique]